when it comes to dating and
relationships who is typically seen as
the prize the man or the woman the woman
oh the woman who's seen as the prize it
really depends no both depends on who's
the prize in the relation ship sometimes
it's the man sometimes it's the woman
that's how sometimes there's some ugly
ass low quality guys pulling some
baddies yeah and vice versa the woman
the woman
so if the woman is the prize What would
a man the wallet
yeah bruh doesn't that place the man at
a lower value and status to the woman
yeah exactly yes
don't women typically want to date a man
on her level or higher yeah
yeah
yes
so don't women typically want to date a
man who's a prize and not a loser
no I like to be better
so if a woman declares herself the prize
isn't that relationship destined to fail
no both of them should feel like they
won the lottery if everybody doesn't
feel like they won the lottery you're in
the wrong relationship if you think I'm
the prize and he's the recipient and he
should just you know polish me and make
me feel like treat me like a queen
forever yeah and you're treating him
like your [ __ ] Court Jester then
you're a jerk and vice versa everybody
you should it should be a king and a
queen and you treat each other as such
everybody's a prize oh yeah or nobody's
surprise but if I'm gonna walk around
being like oh he's lucky he got me a
break slap that [ __ ] that's the prize
wouldn't that make the man a simp yes
and there are Simpson in this world like
if there are high value men and other
people who respect himself but do you
think that women want a data Sim some
women do someone want to be Alpha and a
boss [ __ ] you know I mean it depends on
the male if the mill is like a beta then
he just gonna suck it up and follow
behind the female but if he's an alpha
he gonna be like I'm not taking that
facts because I think
I know I'm a prize and so I think that a
man should value me for what I am it's
much harder to find a high value man
than it is an average woman I can [ __ ]
any girl out here but for her to find a
man who has clout status money
influence all that personality and
whatnot it's way harder who's funny tall
six foot that's so true though those
high value men are way more rare why do
you think women
are also very rare I think high value
human beings are unfortunately rarer
than just commonest [ __ ] yeah it's
hard to find a high value man but it is
hard to find a high value woman too I
mean look at that look at what you got
to sift through yeah I mean I guess if
you're going for like the smartest of
the the hottest girls then obviously
yeah it's gonna be hard to find one why
does so many women think they have a
golden [ __ ] when every woman has one
entitlement name of the game straight up
do you believe in gender equality
absolutely
yeah how can men and women ever be equal
if [ __ ] costs more money than dick I
honestly don't think we will ever be
equal I think that that is a dream that
we would love to have and that's
something that we can pursue it's not
something you love to have and is this
the same girl that just called men the
wallet or is that a different girl yeah
no this is the same girl and the fact
that she even responded to that question
without turning around and going you
know what don't talk to me that way one
walk away is the way is is just shows
her value right there a lady would have
turned around and said you know what
crash you're not we're not even having
that conversation we find some scaring
to talk to find some skank to talk to
but I don't truly think that we will
ever be treated the same I don't think
that's possible How likely will women
pay for dick or make [ __ ] free I don't
think they will ever have to pay for
dick because I feel like men just always
want it so we could just get it whenever
we want versus men can't necessarily get
it whenever they want so then what are
we fighting for Equal Pay I already get
equal pay and when men have to buy you
everything and you get everything for
free it's almost like you get a bonus
every time you walk out the front door
is it harder for a man to get the woman
he wants into bed or for a woman to get
the man she wants to commit harder for a
man to get the woman he wants in bed
most dudes are lame they don't have game
they're not cool they're not funny smart
tall handsome all that [ __ ] don't have
money that's harder for them
a woman can must use she wants to holler
at one man to get the man she wants to
commit I would say if women think men
are trapped dad but she can't
necessarily get him to commit because
everybody's a hoe out there these days
you've done a young lady it's like why
does the guy have to even commit when he
can just go to the buffet all the time
you know it's become a lot easier in
recent years than before when you had to
like really work for it and build your
status up as a guy well because women
just just think they're just out there
and they're like sexual Freedom I'm free
and this and that and then they complete
they can't figure out why they're why
they're depressed and can't get a good
boyfriend Ash why are they so interested
in getting his commitment maybe for
security a lot of these [ __ ] don't be
like feeling like they got to be like
wife material baby yeah you do yeah you
do even if you do what you do in the
streets baby yeah you do you got to cook
you gotta clean you gotta do all that
you feel me you gotta up you gotta abide
by your man's rules you gotta battle
down you gotta do you feel me literally
as much as she's speaking through like
you know her own language she's she's
not wrong
and I wish she didn't have all those
tattoos because this girl is so pretty
look at her I wish that she's got paw
prints and a lock she probably likes
dogs
a teardrop but it's not a regular prison
I killed somebody teardrop it's like
somebody I love killed somebody teardrop
like what's going on there girl look at
her she's got gorgeous skin she's got
gorgeous that teeth everything yeah
she's not bad looking no it's just like
she just literally stop saying like in
between every other word and get rid of
all those tattoos and but she's right
her philosophy is already right the big
lashes is weird but like I'm not a fan
of tattoos on a face that's weird not
all but a lot of women will leverage sex
over men so is it fair for a man to
leverage attention and resources over
women I don't think it's fair either way
however I do think that any like when it
comes to sex the way the cookie crumbles
it should be a consensual thing
regardless so if someone doesn't want to
then they shouldn't have to no matter
what it should be there either we feel
pressured too yeah you can feel
pressured and everyone's about feeling
so much nowadays you know what I mean
that's all everyone thinks about they
shouldn't feel pressured too like shut
up if that's like if there's some
Dynamic you shouldn't hold
um yeah you don't hold something over
their head like just to be like spiteful
spike is [ __ ] if you can't truly care
about somebody you're gonna come
together and try to solve a problem not
be like silent treatment that's kind of
low-key abusive and so if you're also
pressuring somebody to do something but
if you're not if somebody has really
gotten on your nerves and you're like I
am turned off by you that's a different
story yeah that's not withholding that's
just like ew I hate you right now no not
doing that what is the best and the
worst thing about being a woman the best
thing about being a woman is like is
being a woman I think it's like being
like yeah I'm a woman and it's
incredible and the worst thing is like
having to be afraid all the time walking
around here alone or any place okay is
it realistic to think that nobody agree
with it's really annoying as a woman hey
thanks for the Super Chat base mom is
the best oh my God thank you you're
awesome
and I can I can honestly say do you
remember you guys remember this song by
uh no doubt Gwen Stefani was the lead
singer and it was I'm just a girl and it
was about you know oh poor little me I
can't go out late at night and it was it
was like a women's rights feminist song
about how people are overly protective
of women and it's a really good catchy
song and I really like it and and
there's and there's some part of me that
agrees with it that like all right calm
down I got I'm okay to you know do
certain things but it is frustrating as
a woman and oh do you get the more aware
you are of your surroundings that like
if I just am kind of in the mood to go
into the Manhattan in the middle of the
night just go go find a diner and get
something to eat you know maybe I gotta
Park two blocks away and walk there I'm
like I'm not gonna do that because it's
not safe for me and God knows what could
happen you know where a dude might think
twice about it but only twice you know
and then and then he goes anyway so it
is frustrating as a woman so I agree
with her about that but that's just the
world I mean if I was you know Ronda
Rousey again you beat up most of the
human comments male or female look at
it's just how it's safer you don't do
dumb [ __ ] I mean I'm sorry you can't go
on walks alone in the middle of the
night it's also not smart for guys to do
that alone because then you could you're
obviously vulnerable you could easily
come up against a group of guys that'll
just mug you so but as a woman you
you're you're uh yeah you're like if you
go for an hour to go out to go out alone
is earlier and it's just it's just
annoying it's not it is one of the worst
things about being a woman it's not the
end of the world though they're not
gonna make a federal case out of it
because the world is what it is
um ever feel unsafe if it's realistic I
don't know but it's like my my dream
well I mean here's the thing okay just
because women feel afraid all the time
does that mean they really have a right
to be afraid all the time when well at
the same time if a woman is attacked in
public and a man is attacked in public
who is more likely to be rescued I don't
know I think I think
sorry I guess you're afraid
that's a post drama from my home do you
think men are the biggest threat to
women or are men the biggest Protectors
of women they can go either way honestly
I mean it's the good men out there that
want to protect them there's also a bad
man that want to do Terrible Things the
good men are the greatest Protectors of
women there are bad men we hear those
stories all day every day about the bad
guys or would it be [ __ ] news if it
wasn't an exception ah this guy's like
oh man you're so bad no 99 out of 100
men more than that that I've ever come
across I've either been wonderful to me
or just benign and neutral one in ten
thousand you're saying it is a monster
everyone's awesome most people are
awesome I'm sorry to to be the bearer of
bad news for the worksters roasters it's
not as bad as you think that's
assaulting there's also a good guy
that's there to save yeah but aren't
most cops and soldiers men
yes
what percentage of men that you
encounter a cat call you a lot uh
probably 85 like we were just touched
like multiple times some guy grabbed my
nose about 20 minutes ago oh my God it
is a pretty nose I will give you that yo
no one's
85
85 of men that she ate eight eight out
of ten guys out of ten guys she walks by
go damn [ __ ] no they don't damn
what's the craziest thing someone said
cat calling to you have they ever said
like some crazy like or like a funny
moment not like crazy me I don't know
I'll think about it while we're playing
I like this stupid [ __ ] is like damn
girl you work out oh gee as a guy as a
guy [ __ ] fortune cookie you remember
literally every time a girl's ever like
yeah I called you remember it's as a guy
you could list them you could list like
everything what's yours tell me your cat
call stories I mean just being in a bar
um there's been times where I'm just
like walking and then the girls just
like oh he's cute or like oh you so cute
there's a time or during like the feast
girls would just come up to you and be
like Oh my your Snapchat just like Ugh
like just get away from me yeah no I
don't know like growing up you know as a
teenager I was always walking in
Manhattan and hanging out there and you
know there'd be like construction sites
and there'd be people saying stuff
frankly I I didn't take the time to get
Negative if like some guys were like
whistling at me from a third level
scaffold I'd be like hey and I keep
walking like I'm like I'm not gonna get
at all my favorite my favorite thing to
do is is cat call girls when I'm driving
my convertible just give them a wave oh
that's not cat calling giving them a
wave is not catcalling that's it that's
a polite
well I guess I don't know
whistling it's like oh I can't whistle
but like the river whistle and then
there's the um yeah yeah hey baby or
damn girl or all right well then not cat
calling me and my friends we're all good
a good looking damn good legs what's up
you know the smile wave as they're
eating dinner they're on their Night Out
in Boston we're just cruise I've had
guys like do this weird tongue thing as
they drove by yeah people do creepy [ __ ]
that's weird I'm saying how often do you
fear for your safety when a man cat
calls you 100 all the time now I'm not
excusing it why is cat calling such a
big deal I think cat calling is such a
big deal because I'm not out here
dressed like this you can give a little
oh my end of the outfit this is not for
others view this is for me
that's the funniest part because then
they'll wear [ __ ] like this there were
skimpy outfits in the winter and they'll
stand there
get out of here because you could you
dress like that and you do your hair and
you put on all that makeup when you're
home alone okay pumpkin we buy that
that's the funny that's the that's one
of the dumbest [ __ ] that the girls will
say it's for me yeah I'm out of here and
this is what I feel most comfortable in
this is not an invitation for you to
come objectify me or decide that this
body is meant for you it's mine okay and
and that's fair I agree with that right
now she got there oh all of a sudden she
put on her Hillary Clinton you know uh
ugly pantsuit there this is for me so
let me tell you something so grab my
base Grandma I don't know if you guys
watch the bass Grandma video Grandma
reacted to Tate that's my mom where you
saw her in that video blouse hair
jewelry makeup that woman looks like
that 24 hours a day to the point where
I'm like Jesus Christ lady can you ever
relax no she can't relax ever so she'll
sit in her house all day like when she
wakes up to go watch TV downstairs to
put on full makeup and lipstick and an
outfit and shoes and she looks like like
if anybody Ed McMahon the Publishers
Clearing House writing the bell with the
camera to say you want a million dollars
a month for life she would be like oh
wonderful come on in she wouldn't be
like in some skanky bathroom right so
that's a woman who dresses the way she
dresses for her even all through covid
that woman looks like Queen Elizabeth
every single day it was weird and like I
think that's an old-fashioned thing this
girl is saying she dresses like this for
her it's [ __ ] yeah yeah you don't
you don't like the attention when it
when a good looking high value man gives
her an up and down she's like
I know it been there kiddo um because
watch if they start getting no attention
if she got cat called never again she'd
miss it she'd be like oh why don't
people why are people coming in 20 years
she's gonna be like I'm so old nobody
notices me anymore yeah she's gonna miss
it get out of here get out of here for a
lot of women who say they dress for
themselves why do you often see women
walking around in uncomfortable shoes
and skimpy outfits when it's freezing
outside cause I made that money that I'm
gonna spend that money on some cute
heels and I worked on this body and I'm
gonna show it off no no I guess that's
what I'm saying for you again okay so I
dressed like this for me and I'm gonna
show it off are you even listening to
yourself women moment if a woman has
lots of sexy photos on her dating
profile and no bio should she be
surprised if guys are only contacting
her for hookups oh absolutely yes no
definitely not why not because she's
kind of asking for that attention is she
not promoting herself in the same
fashion if she's out walking the streets
in the [ __ ] outfit no no so why why
would it make a difference you're on a
dating app that's like there's like a
reason you're on that app I mean if
you're in person people don't have like
their [ __ ] profile above their head
so I guess that is kind of different
right not everybody at a dating app is
is dressing like a hoe and acting like
that and same with men some men some
people on dating apps are truly looking
for more than a hookup it's like Tinder
you don't go on Tinder if you when you
belong on eHarmony no
what am I missing on Tinder it's always
like the fattest girls and they're like
they [ __ ] ain't free you got a wife you
gotta wife me up to get some of this
like the whales It's the funniest thing
oh well you know good for them they got
a little you know they had the most
confidence but for most confidence and
self-respect
what are you doing on Tinder I mean yeah
no that's just you gotta get off Tinder
they're online or out in public because
you're posting those
four like a specific dating app while
while you
while you're outside it's like how you
want to dress I dress this way because I
want to dress this way for me and not
for anyone else and also at least here
if you're going to a club they have uh
dress codes and you have you have to
dress a certain way in order to get in
and that is yeah she was she actually
didn't sound as dumb as the other girl
saying that like I am wearing like me
Sonny's mother I'm wearing this shirt
because I like it wearing it because I
like it it's for me but you know if
you're doing things that other girl
who's like I want to show up my body and
it's just for me clearly you're dressing
skimply to get attention and there's no
arguing that and she she can't she can
pretend all day long why do you think
women can't just ignore cat calling
instead of just hating on all men uh
because when we kept like when we ignore
cat calling they don't stop like they'll
just come up to us and like be more in
our face and more aggressive when we do
ignore this happens to her I don't
really think there's a way to win
there's been I'm sorry I was just sweaty
God I'm sorry God God forgive you no
that was made in 20. you're not wrong
though I said said the same thing she's
a little better looking no like the girl
the
more attractive that's the girl
you can ignore it and they back or
there's been times when unfronted it and
they back off or
I don't say anything I continue to get
followed I do say something I put myself
in even more danger so you really just
have to get this like on the regular on
the regular eight and a half out of ten
men can't call her and then some of them
regularly follow her to the point where
it's an issue in her life this is this
is what I'm gleaning from what she has
said so far so many men are cat calling
you would you maybe think it's because
of what I'm wearing and to change that
if you're actually that scared by it
wouldn't you be like okay there's a
dangerous thing happening to me all the
time maybe I should do something I'm
being over sexualized by men and it has
nothing to do with what I'm wearing now
maybe cover your abdomen put your
boobies away and maybe have something
that's a little looser when you're
walking down the street and what streets
is she walking down that this happens so
much what Gauntlet is she walking
through every day is every time I go out
no matter how I look someone is being in
a park with me and that's when it
becomes an issue because it isn't
appropriate and I don't mind like you
say inappropriate things happen every
day like people either touching you or
are trying to get something from you but
when it's I can imagine that's why
celebrities struggle being a celebrity
status because they are constantly
hounded for attention and that's how I
feel when a guy whistles at me right but
but the fact that you bring up
celebrities right if you ask a celebrity
if you had to give up the idea of being
famous in order to never ever deal with
Paparazzi would they give up the
privilege of being famous probably not
would you give up the privilege of being
sexy as [ __ ]
are we just gonna pretend all right that
you dress attract the type of attention
you want not always not always
so is it fair to blame society or is it
better to just change the behavior what
was the question if they said not always
does dressing affect the way that people
approach you and the way like your your
interactions like yes if you're dressed
like a complete hoe like more people are
going to come up to you and treat you
differently right the answer is not
always it it's like sort of true but
even just forget sexualization what do I
tell you about traveling how to dress
when you're getting on an airplane you
say where you say dress like a gentleman
on a plane dress like a gentleman put on
a put on a collared shirt wear good
shoes and a nice pair of pants and
you're going to be treated differently
by everyone that meets you and it's just
the truth and there was so frustrating
that people like you should be treated
no matter what no you're in a filthy
T-shirt with stains all over it and rip
sweatpants and dirty sneakers you know
let's just get to the reality of human
nature you are not going to be treated
the same as the gentleman even if he's
wearing inexpensive clothes from an
inexpensive yeah they are clean and
they're are oppressed and he's wearing
pants and a button-down shirt and a
clean pair of shoes on the plane he's
going to be treated better and more
people are going to want to sit next to
him let's just be real and the fact that
these women don't understand that the
way you present yourself affects your
interface with the world is a shame and
I I do hope that they learn that these
look like young women hopefully they'll
learn that and they'll be able to teach
their children that instead of adopting
more victim mentality I don't know I
would say that Society is the reason
that a lot of the problems that we see
with dating nobody takes
self-accountability for anything all
everyone blames their problems on is
society and other [ __ ] and that's part
of the indoctrination from when you're
little just tell you to [ __ ] always
look up to this bigger thing if you have
any problems go tell the teacher and
then when you're an adult it's rely on
the government and then people wonder
why like you're [ __ ] sad when you
can't deal with any problems yourself
personal responsibility all day long I
take the steps to make myself feel safer
I carry weapons to be able to protect
myself I learn how to ward off that
attention I I've learned how to gauge
the body language of if I yell at this
man for hitting on me is he going to
become dangerous or is he going to go
away I've learned how to understand that
and figure out what to do in that
situation and one last question which I
think you just touched upon I asked
um when does blaming Society end and
personal responsibility begin I haven't
even watched this before yes ever you're
ready to accept it I think it's
everyone's timeline I don't think it's
I'm going to get off social media and
realize that I'm the problem I think
everyone a part of them is like no the
world's against me it's not that you're
necessarily the problem it's that you
have to take personal responsibility and
realize that your actions result in
consequences to you wearing different
clothes might result in different
exchanges with people everything you do
has a result you know what in Israel
women are badasses they can beat the
[ __ ] out of guys you know what I mean
but I'm just saying maybe maybe maybe
more American women should serve in the
Army and they'll know how to defend
themselves maybe more men needs to like
not be attacking well I think we can do
both maybe I think we can do both I
don't condone the guys who do that [ __ ]
I can wear pants I can wear a top that
shows most of my body and I continue to
do so because of all the women who
fought for that women women didn't fight
for you to walk around looking like a
[ __ ] okay that's not what they fought
for they fought for your right to vote
they're right for your education the
right for you to play a sport Jesus
Christ I just thought of a good analogy
a big reason why I don't wear like
expensive chains expensive clothes and
jewelry because I don't want to get
robbed like I I realized that wearing
that kind of [ __ ] could result in a bad
consequence you know so I we you and I
have talked about that I've told you
about that like you're right in the
Subway put your chain on the inside if
you insist on wearing it please don't
wear it tonight but if you must put it
inside right we've talked about that so
there was a um I think it was iced tea
it's been in the news this week how a
bunch of the rappers in La aren't
wearing their bling and I think it was
ICE Steve somebody will crack me if I'm
wrong who said we're not going to
attempt there's no need to tempt the
streets shit's bad out there and we
don't need to make trouble for ourselves
so you get these grown-ass tough men
with security guards who are like yeah I
don't need to wear my blank ask for
trouble yeah and that's common sense
that we were raised and raise with why
are you asking for trouble you're asking
for it if I walk around flexing money
and then you're just walking around
flexing your titties all the time
bragging and you recognize that men are
extremely like horny individuals and
they'll do weird stuff and then you
still go around flexing and showing off
the thing they want and then you still
don't take personal responsibility for
that there's a like there's a reason for
that consequence yeah and it's not like
we're justifying that men do bad [ __ ]
it's just like you have to acknowledge
that what you do results in something
you have to live in the world that you
live in not in the world that you want
to live in there's a reason I don't wear
expensive [ __ ] I don't want to get
robbed and this guy right to vote this
girl is saying this is what women fought
for so I can dress like this for for I
know you know what I was trying to say
I'm getting mad I feel you let's watch
it continue to do so because of all the
women who fought women got the right to
vote 102 years ago that's it there are
women older than that on this planet who
were not able to legally vote for the
leadership in this country we do this
for them don't even get me started
voting like a [ __ ] for Susan B Anthony
and for all the women who weren't
allowed to vote
I
should be Anthony's the one that
couldn't vote thank you I'm I'm wearing
I'm showing my titties for you remember
when Susan B Anthony did oh look at me
where the [ __ ] for them we do what we
want we have sex with whoever we want
for them because we are still continuing
to fight even her friends
at my place of employment wish there was
a speech bubble above the blonde's head
because she's going my friends she's
going what the [ __ ] are you saying what
the [ __ ] are you saying right now you
look like it you sound like an idiot you
some I don't and and she wants to look
at the camera and be like I don't I
don't agree I don't agree you can see it
in her eyes I like this one on the right
this one is just a because she's just
leaving some talking points that
somebody in her college dorm told her to
say oh poor thing your father is
fringing right now watching this yeah I
hope he never sees it I hope he never
sees it and my professional place of
employment I am treated like a child or
like a sex object every single day of my
life and I'm gonna keep on fighting to
make that not [ __ ] happen or to make
that so that I can feel safe being able
to look as I do and to be as young as I
am and go out and be completely safe and
I'm going to keep on fighting for that
you're a [ __ ] Nimrod I'm so glad that
I don't have a daughter and I'm double
glad that's not my daughter what what
the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] I feel sorry
for her parents
trust me I'm not mentally ill it's just
that I've been